Natacha my sister after all this time
what brings you home
[Applause]
I was trying to do something doing
[Music]
any more than just a trained killer
you're fooling yourself we're still both
trained killers
[Music]
we have unfinished business
[Music]
as we
still fits family back together again
you got fat smelly waterway
there's a new wardrobe what else
new enemies
I'm done running from my past
[Music]
that was that guy
[Music]
how's it going everybody it's Warren and
we just got brand-new footage for the
Black Widow movie this was just released
during the college football national
championship and Marvell posted it not
too long after it is just packed with a
ton of new footage so let's jump right
into it real quick if you're new to my
channel be sure to subscribe to stay
up-to-date on everything relating to the
MCU so we start off with some new
footage and new dialogue of Alaina
Bulova talking to her sister Natasha she
says my sister after all this time what
brings you home
she says I'm on the run I was trying to
do something good trying to be more than
just a trained killer and what she's
referring to here is the events of
Captain America's Civil War and not just
the events of Captain America Civil War
but the events of Hawkeye turning her
making her good her joining the Avengers
and working for shield but she's on the
run after the events of Captain America
Civil War because she helped out Steve
Rogers and Bucky but then Yelena Bulova
says you're fooling yourself we're both
still trained killers this is obviously
true this is something that they can
never really get away from they've had
to training their minds take a certain
way and even right now Black Widow is on
a new assignment even though it's given
to her by herself and that's why she
says we have unfinished business and
then Yelena says who is we and then we
see this awesome new fight with red
Guardian he's breaking out of the prison
and absolutely destroying the guards
that are trying to stop him from getting
out remember he's the Russian Captain
America he has a form of Super Soldier
Serum in him so he's incredibly strong
like Steve Rogers and then we even see
Malina
vosdek aah fight for the first time as
well she looks awesome
then the family gets back together just
like we saw in the teaser trailer this
time a little bit added to the fat joke
where Malina says you got fat red
Guardian says it's mostly water weight
and then we find out a little bit more
about the plot to Black Widow Black
Widow says there's a new world of widows
and it shows all of the girls who are
being trained to be assassins to be
Black Widow and then it shows them in
the field as well we see one of them
taking a sniper shot and then she says
there's new enemies and we get our first
look at Natasha and taskmaster fighting
each other and what's interesting is
that after she says new enemies and we
see taskmaster she says I'm done running
from my past and then it shows
taskmaster again
his shield and if he noticed taskmaster
moves exactly like Captain America moves
he blocks the bullets the same way and
even throws this shield the same way as
well and what makes taskmaster so deadly
is that he actually mimics other
people's attacks so when you're fighting
him he'll figure out your fighting style
and mimic it and use it against you so
he could be copying a little bit of red
guardians Captain America then there's
this awesome new scene of Natasha
Romanoff as Black Widow of course
fighting the other trained black widows
then we have another amazing combat
scene of taskmaster as he jumps over
Black Widow as she is trying to shoot
him but he deflects all of the bullets
with his shield we then hear black were
to say who the hell is that guy and we
see them come face-to-face for the very
first time and it's absolutely epic so
that's it for the new exclusive look of
Black Widow was absolutely fantastic but
let me know what you thought about this
how excited are you for the black movie
to come out in May let me know in the
comments down below and don't forget to
give the video a like and subscribe to
my channel the notifications turned on
to enter my giveaway for a chance to win
an Xbox one or ps4 I'm picking a winner
and 550,000 subscribers don't forget to
follow me on Instagram and Twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching well off
[Music]